l'avantagé qu'ils connaissent la région
déjà donc de prendre des régisseurs ou
des repéreurs de région c'est un grand
intérêt c'est un enfant un super cadre
est aussi un moyen de vraiment se
concentrer sur le projet avec des supers
moments technique en 1991 la région
centre créé la paix cvl un outil chargé
de développer le cinéma dans la région
une poignée de salariés cinéphiles et
une furieuse envie de défendre le
septième art
très vite les choix s'avère payant les
récompenses pleuvent la vie rêvée des
anges le bleu des villes où la princesse
de montpensier
autant de films soutenus et autant de
prix décrochés dans les grands festivals
comme cannes biarritz et bien d'autres
[Musique]
animations
il ya des enfants qui ne peuvent pas
aller au cinéma avec leurs parents donc
ça leur leur permet de venir avec nous
faire une séance de cinéma
on valorise ses films et les gens y
trouvent un intérêt dedans c'est des
choses qu'ils ont vécu ou tout
simplement cédé passionné c'est à dire
sont des gens qui s'intéressent à
l'histoire locale
aujourd'hui la structure s'est
développée et diversifiée
elle a changé de nom si à l'occasion de
sa fusion avec libre au centre
elle s'appelle désormais cycliques et
s'est fortement enracinée dans le
paysage régional
revue de détail
[Musique]
nous sommes à château-renault au siège
de cyclique
aujourd'hui c'est jour de réunion
c'est un peu une urgence et la
préparation des films de jean yanne une
estrade je n'influence parce qu'ils
n'ont pas bénéficié du soutien de la
région ile de france
l'objet de cette réunion c'est de
préparer l'accueil du film de jean
xavier de lestrade jeux d'influencé qui
était donc soutenu à la production par
cycliques et l'agencement du val de
loire et qui prévoit de tourner plus ou
moins entre quatre et six semaines on
sait pas encore exactement puisque en
phase de préparation de ce tournage sur
le territoire régional
l'accueil de tournages dans la région
c'est l'une des missions de cyclique
mais le rôle de cet organisme financé
par l'état et la région ne s'arrête pas
là on apporte un développement d'une
politique et du développement d'une
communauté d'une filière professionnelle
accompagné aussi et ça je pense que
c'est fondamental par rapport aux
pouvoirs publics c'est d'accompagner des
auteurs émergents et des des auteurs
émergents mais aussi répondre à la
première demande des producteurs de
cinéma trouver des lieux pour leurs
tournages une maison bourgeoise on a les
contacts évidemment du propriétaire on a
les coordonnées du décor on cherche dans
notre base de données quelles peuvent
être les maisons qui peuvent
correspondre aux critères répétition
changement de décor nous sommes à saint
georges sur cher dans l'une de ses
maisons qui sert de lieu de tournage
pour le prochain film de jean xavier de
lestrade cycliques accompagne les films
dans leurs aspects financiers et
artistique est également en leur
fournissant un soutien logistique très
concret l'avantagé qu'ils connaissent la
région déjà donc de prendre des
régisseurs ou des repéreurs de région
c'est un grand intérêt puisqu'ils
connaissent la région
donc c'est un gain de temps avec le
directeur de production donc pas de 3d
on a vraiment travaillé de manière assez
fine est étroite pour trouver dans
chacune des équipes techniques et les
équipes maquillage des équipes habillage
les équipes décoration les équipes
électriciens les équipes
régis et atsé trouver les compétences
qu'ils pouvaient être trouvés sur le
territoire régional pour compléter cette
équipe avec des forces vives du
territoire régional
mathieu est l'un des techniciens
tourangeau choisi par la production d'un
vrai côté familial au niveau des équipes
techniques tourangelle et la région
centre
en général on se connaît tous on est on
est on est quelques dizaines
décorateur
machiniste électricien régisseurs ont
lancé une grosse équipe au régime ici en
touraine est on est on est sollicité
très clairement
vingt à trente films sont ainsi aidées
chaque année et ça fait 25 ans que ça
dure avec à la clé de belles
distinctions pour plusieurs d'entre eux
ça va m'aider moi je suis passé sur ce
projet n'a rien aussi
[Musique]
ici c'est notre salle de projection et
nous sert pour les séances avec le
public et les projections des rencontres
etc les résidents et des ateliers
discussions
c'était important ce qu'on voulait que
la résidence soit ouverte sur la ville
bienvenue à vendôme
c'est ici que depuis 2015 cyclique a
installé son pôle entièrement voué au
cinéma d'animation des locaux
gigantesque et équipé des toutes
dernières technologies capables
d'accueillir simultanément plusieurs
équipes en résidence de création
ici on est dans une salve en titre une
salle noire
ça permet de travailler donc la caméra
est au dessus de ce film est de filmer à
la verticale et nous travailler soit en
papier découpé en peinture en sable sur
verre on a toutes les techniques
d'animation traditionnelle donc les
techniques en volume donc les films en
marionnettes ou en pâte à modeler comme
les chicken run ou à la segro mythe les
films en bon titre nous comme ici et
puis les films en animation 2d dessins
sur papier ou dessins sur ordinateur
courts ou longs métrages séries
télévisées films pour enfants ou
animations plus expérimental
tous ces films d'auteur trouve ici une
aide précieuse c'était pour ces
professionnels parce qu'ils trouvent des
financements
il trouve aussi le principe de la
résidence et de leur donner un cadre de
travail optimales pour
pour faire leur film ont besoin de soins
des espaces de matériel de temps de
tranquillité
[Musique]
ambiance studieuse style start up sur ce
plateau dédié au dessin sur ordinateur
avec des conditions très apprécié des
utilisateurs
c'est à la fois un super cadre est aussi
un moyen vraiment se concentrer sur le
projet avec des super moyens techniques
quoi sébastien onomo et producteurs
d'abord installé à paris il a choisi de
déménager son entreprise il y a un an
pour s'installer à vendôme à deux pas
c'est une ville avec son institution
cynique animation qui est reconnu pour
être un détecteur de talents donc donc
ça nous semblait intéressant par rapport
au travail qu'on fait sur l'innovation
de venir au plus près de cyclique
animations pour pour continuer à grandir
en même temps que cette structure un
festival une structure unique en france
et maintenant l'arrivée de maisons de
production vendôme est devenu
incontournable pour le cinéma
d'animation
[Musique]
je viens de saint-jean-de-la-ruelle au
près d'orléans élevé à lauris pendant ce
temps là à château-renault emilie la
programmatrice fait son choix car c'est
une autre mission de cyclique diffuser
le cinéma jusque dans les plus petites
communes de la région
là où les habitants sont souvent très
éloignés du septième art toutes les
actions portées par la diffusion c'est
ça c'est être dans la découverte essayer
de susciter la curiosité des spectateurs
que ce soit dans les communes où passe
le ciné mobile donc en milieu rural mais
aussi finalement quand on travaille avec
des salles de cinéma les studios tour où
les carmes à orléans où des salles art
et essai plus institué et des petites
salles
généralement on a un film tout public
est un film un film d'animation pour les
enfants
les gens viennent se faire
il voir un film donc ils viennent se
faire plaisir donc la relation avec les
gens et
[Musique]
pas dire familiale et amicale conviviale
un camion presque comme les autres
avant qu'il se transforme en authentique
salles de cinéma d'une centaine de
places dominique se livrent à un
véritable cérémonial où toutes les
opérations d'installation sont
parfaitement rodé c'est impressionnant
la première fois c'est comme tout ça
s'apprend et je vais dire quelque part
c'est le coeur c'est le coeur de la
salle la salle de cinéma parce que c'est
là où se passe la projection c'est là où
ou la billetterie ce passe on a le même
matériel que dans que dans une salle
fixe c'est la même chose force on
apprend sur le tas quoi c'est comme si
un typique comme métier la projection
c'est bien la conduite c'est un autre
métier
les deux ensemble à ce prix là et là je
fais plein 15h30 arrivée des enfants du
centre de loisirs
au programme un dessin animé opération
casse-noisette 2 le ticket il ya des
enfants qui ne peuvent pas aller au
cinéma avec leurs parents donc ça leur
leur permet de venir avec nous faire une
séance de cinéma assez chargé et je
lancerai ses rangs
ce soir place aux as minutes et demain
le camion du ciné mobile sera garé sur
un autre parking dans un autre village
près de 50 communes de la région
bénéficient ainsi de ce service
[Musique]
une séance un peu particulière pour
cette soirée cinémathèque au studio ce
soir on projette devant une salle comble
des films tournés par des cinéastes
amateurs de la région
c'est le pôle patrimoine de cyclique qui
est chargé de faire vivre ce fonds
unique
[Musique]
cette tourangelle est venu apporter son
trésor des images tournées dans
l'immédiate après guerre par son père
alors qu'un cahier bien connu de la rue
de la tranchée à tour c'est le souvenir
ça mais garder pour moi ben on va
d'abord il serait abîmé donc j'ai
préféré les déposer comme ça plutôt que
ce soit abîmée puis à +20 il en a fait
aussi sur des événements sont passés à
tour parce que votre père est tournée
française c'est ça on valorise ses films
et les gens y trouvent un intérêt dedans
c'est des choses qu'ils ont vécu ou tout
simplement cédé passionné c'est à dire
c'est des gens qui s'intéressent à
l'histoire locale et les films amateurs
sont porteurs de ça ils sont pourtant
non seulement de la valeur familiale des
images enregistrées mais ang est
également là comment dire l'intérêt la
valeur documentaire dont ils sont
porteurs
est ce que vous savez ce qu'elle est ce
véhicule quand on le voit sur les images
c'est un véhicule tourangeau produit à
tour dès 1907 celle à roland pilain en
fait ce qui est intéressant c'est de
regarder dans l'arrière-plan et l'on
s'aperçoit encore des stigmates
en fait de la gare qui sont encore bien
présents arrivé à issoudun dans les
locaux du pôle patrimoine de cyclique
les précieux film déposée par notre
tourangelle seront traités ici puis
archivée dans cette salle aux conditions
frigorifique
c'est là où se passe la consternation
physique des films les films que l'on
stocke ici ce sont principalement des
films réalisés par des cinéastes
amateurs depuis les débuts du cinéma
grosso modo depuis 1924 et jusqu'à nos
jours voilà que ça soit en pellicule ou
en vidéo ce sont des documents qui
viennent nous renseigner sur l'évolution
de la vie au xxème siècle dans notre
région la région centre val de loire
alors il ya des partis qui sont parfois
plus familial mais d'autres partis qui
sont à forte valeur documentaire et qui
ont un propos parfois inédits ou qui
sort de ce qui a pu être filmée par les
autorités que ce soit les services des
armées que ce soit la télévision
voilà du cese a passé d'accord c'est
dans ces salles que les précieux films
sont nettoyés indexés et numérisés dix
sept mille films sont ainsi
méthodiquement traité c'est un peu de la
mémoire de notre région qui est
aujourd'hui protéger et valoriser
ah ah
[Musique]
aide à la création mise en réseau des
professionnels locaux soutien au cinéma
d'animation projections dans les
moindres quartiers et villages du
territoire mais aussi sauvegarde et
valorisation des films amateurs le
travail de cyclique est décidément très
diversifié il occupe aujourd'hui une
place de choix dans le paysage
cinématographique français
[Musique]